(upbeat guitar music)
- [Voiceovers] Dead Kevin.
- (laughing) That
is so interesting.
Holy wow, cow.
So you are a fur
j-, you're jogging?
You're a jogger?
- I'm jogging.
Trying to. (laughs)
Usually right here, yeah,
where you're standing
is where I...
You okay?
- Do, what do you do,
like seven, seven K?
- Um, just um, you know.
Just with the legs.
- Sure, yeah, sure.
- Do you ever feel like, you
aren't, you're shouldn't?
Or you aren't, or
you're, you're good?
- I'm sorry.
- Sorry!
- I'm sorry?
- Ah!
(Ryan imitates stuttering)
Okay. (laughing)
Sorry (imitates distress).
- You wanna come by?
- [Woman] Um, I think I'm okay.
I'm just gonna, you know,
finish the, the run that
I'm (laughs) trying to do.
Just tryna run.
- Okay.
After, you can come by after.
- Let's, let's start over.
- Okay.
- This is weird.
Let's start over.
Okay?
- Okay.
- I'm Ryan.
(water hissing)
Ow, Jesus!
- [Man In Car] Loser!
- Shit!
- Are you, are you okay?
- I got the plate.
- I don't think they like you.
- They're punks.
- Oh, make sure it's not urine!
When they got me it
was urine. (laughs)
- I don't even, I don't care.
All I have in my eyes
is holy way-yo-yo-yo.
How much, how are you
fr-, how do you sleep?
- Okay.
- Not like, what do you wear.
- Not what do you, no no no,
not what do you wear for it.
- Pajamas?
- Just, I don't know.
- So, how are, you're
around, oh, you're around it?
- Um what, what was, I didn't
catch that last, uh, that--
- You were making me happy.
You're making me happy!
So who am I to refer
to complain? (giggles)
(sputtering) Jesus!
Shit!
(men in car laughing)
You fucking pricks!
You dicks!
- Is...?
- Um, I'm like eh, ah.
- They got him good on that one.
- Yeah I'm uh, so I'm
like not, I'm not that.
So if you ever need
not that, that's me.
- [Woman] Oh, wow.
- (panting) He got away.
- Did you, what happened, man?
You got beat up?
- No, I didn't get beat, I
didn't get beat up. (laughing)
- You're, you have blood
from your nose.
- (laughing) You ain't so
handsome no more! (laughing)
Woo!
- Eh, I don't even,
what did you do?
What did you do?
- Are you all right?
- Where were you?
- Let's go to the hospital.
- We're gonna go, we're gonna
take him to the hospital.
- I like you, I want you.
- Hey, hey.
You wanna come to the hospital?
- I'm a virgin if
you wanted that.
- I'll, I'll see you there.
- Hey, let's go,
let's go to the hospital.
- So I'll see ya at the,
okay, all right.
See you at the E.R.,
I'll get, all right.
- We're always up
to things like this.
- [woman] Okay.
- Woo! (laughing)
It's a good day to be
homeless. (laughing)
(acoustic guitar music)
(laughing) That was
quite a tale, wasn't it?
Please like and subscribe.
Also, in the comments
section, leave us a story
about your most awkward
hitting-on-a-woman situation.
Bye.
- [Voiceover] Wow.
Wow.